uh shireen week 11 is upon us it's time
to talk about the things we can't wait
to see and we selected that amalgamation
of sound because that leads into your
first choice
it does i want to see if the raiders can
take another victory lap on the chiefs
and you know hey whatever gets you
motivated but it was hilarious to me
that this came from the chiefs
considering they're the team that among
other things in 2016 if you remember
they were blowing out the denver broncos
and they decided to have don terry poe
out of fun throw a touchdown pass in the
final two minutes to to run up the score
on the broncos so you know these
rivalries in the afc west like a lot of
these divisions are intense and this is
one of the most intense rivalries in
football and i am excited to see this
one on sunday and the chiefs last year
they avenged a couple of losses they
avenged a loss to the texans in the
regular season did that in the
postseason they eventually lost the
titans in the regular season the
postseason they get another chance at
the raiders before the postseason even
gets here and look out raiders who've
had some covet issues this week that's
going to make it much harder to
duplicate what they did the last time
yeah that's absolutely right all those
guys on the covet 19 reserve list plenty
of them eligible to come back but they
won't be prepared for the game and that
gives the chiefs a bit of an edge and
the chiefs when
their full focus is devoted to an
opponent they seem to be much better
because think about it week in and week
out they're always getting the absolute
a plus game of everyone they play it's a
measuring stick it's a mini super bowl
can we take down the champions the
raiders unfortunately for them now we're
fortunate enough to do it five weeks ago
which only means you're not going to
sneak up on the chiefs this time and
it's going to be a challenge to slow
them down so maybe the chiefs will be
taking the victory lap around the giant
roomba in the desert which is the new
raiders stadium all right i can't wait
to see what aaron rodgers does against
that vaunted and underrated colts
defense they won't have denico autry
this week he's on covet but they have
plenty of other great players and
the story about aaron rodgers all year
long has been what help does he really
have aaron jones has been banged up he
should be good to go devonta adams is
banged up who knows what he ultimately
will be able to do marquez valdez
scantling was great last week so you
know that there is help for aaron
rodgers but maybe not enough as they
face arguably the best defense they've
seen all year and this is an opportunity
for them to continue
to to tighten their grip
on the number one seed in the nfc while
the nfc west teams fight amongst
themselves and weaken each other's
records and while the saints try to hold
on with drew brees out this really is
the chance for the packers to run away
with home field advantage and the
all-important only one team gets it per
conference buy that's going to be
available coming up in january assuming
the playoff field doesn't expand to 16
shireen
and you know what mike we talk about
motivation darius leonard said he wanted
to prove to aaron rodgers that he was
the best linebacker in football you'll
remember back in that 49ers game aaron
rodgers went up to fred warner and said
you're the best linebacker in football
well darius leonard heard that so he
snapped back this week and said lamar
jackson was a much more dangerous
quarterback to face than aaron rodgers
so this thing's getting really
interesting here with the colts the
number one defense in football and
wanting to prove that uh and matt
everflus frankly has to be right up
there and assistant coach of the year
with what he's done with that defense
they've been terrific
yeah and and the team you know they have
that up and down vibe but they have been
far more up than down they just kind of
get overlooked they slide into the big
spot at 425 eastern thanks to the luster
being gone from the cowboys in the
vikings game so we'll get to keep a
close eye on what the packers and the
colts can do against each other both
need the game all right shireen what
else can't you wait to see
i can't wait to see a rematch between
the ravens and the titans we talked
about some of these games in the
postseason that we saw and you know we
remember derek henry running for 195
yards and lamar jackson didn't play like
the lamar jackson who won the
mvp award in the regular season and they
really frankly kind of dominated that
game and a lot of the moves that the
ravens made in the off season were
intended to stop teams like the titans
that could really run the ball they
traded for caleus campbell they signed
derek
and now you have campbell and brandon
williams are injured and they've got to
have guys step up and they didn't last
week and the patriots ran for 173 yards
against them so i think derek henry is
going to have a very big game in this
game but this game to me is very crucial
for both of these teams with where they
stand neither team can afford to lose
this game the titans have been on this
mini kind of losing streak over the past
four games they have not played well
they're in a nick and nip and tuck race
with the with the colts for the division
and then the ravens are just so far back
of the steelers important game for both
of these teams
and a point that peter king made earlier
today on pft live the loss of taylor
lawn their left tackle for the season
that coincided with the dip in the
offensive production still was strange
earlier this week when quarterback ryan
tannehill was the one explaining to the
media why there's been a deliberate
effort to reduce derek henry's touches
they were 5-0 when derek henry was
getting the ball as much as he was but
maybe that absence of taylor lawon makes
it harder to generate the kind of
offense they had but this is huge
because one of these two teams could end
up missing the playoffs and whoever
loses on sunday and falls to uh six and
four is going to be in a potential mess
down the stretch because the afc very
competitive for those playoff berths i
can't wait to see even though the game
itself means absolutely nothing joe
burrow the first overall pick in the
draft and chase young the second overall
pick at one time ohio state teammates
urban meyer tweeted out that photo of
chase young trying to sack joe burrow in
practice and looked like he was not
respecting the quarterback don't touch
him jersey in the photo that meyer
tweeted but joe burrow has been touched
plenty by defensive lineman this year he
gets hit a lot he keeps going and i
guess one thing he has to be ready for
is the possibility he's going to be hit
after he throws the ball because that's
what chase young did on sunday to set up
the lions for the game-winning field
goal i doubt that chase young will ever
do that one again but that adds a little
luster to a game that otherwise you look
at and say two six and one versus two
and seven who the hell cares that's a
reason to care about that game
it is and chase young has a chance to
get back in the defensive rookie of the
year conversation we've kind of
forgotten about him he had two great
games got hurt and then started getting
double teams when he came back we kind
of forgot about him but he has a chance
now mike to get back in that
conversation
all right what do you have next on your
list sharing
well i want to see if the cowboys best
player according to jerry jones is going
to show up against the best running back
in the nfl this season and they go head
to head i mean they're not on the field
at the same time obviously but ezekiel
elliott it was curious to me that jerry
jones today called ezekiel elliot the
cowboys best player and
i don't agree with it i don't even know
if he's their best running back tony
pollard has averaged 4.4 yards a carry
to elliot's 3.8 elliot leads all running
backs with four fumbles and you know
what he's almost 400 yards behind alvin
cook in the rushing race he's not going
to win it he's won it two times dalvin
cook is the reason that the vikings
arrow is pointed up and to me ezekiel
elliott is the reason the cow other than
losing dak prescott but he hasn't
stepped up since prescott
got out of the lineup and that is reason
the cowboys arrow is pointed down even
though they remain in the nfc east race
i don't know what jerry's thinking
saying ezekiel it's the best player on
the team but he always has his reasons
even if there really is no reason for
saying whatever it is that he chooses to
say and i don't write the cowboys often
this one uh the vikings defense has been
suspect at times and that two weeks to
get ready and andy dalton coming back
maybe they can find a way to play like
they did a couple of weeks ago against
the steelers and maybe
maybe
uh it's not it's not an emotional hedge
or reverse jinx it's just reality
it's you know we should have some sort
of a wager on this game if we
either of us gave a crap about either
these teams right now they both stink
even though the vikings have won three
in a row they got a long way to go to
truly get themselves into playoff
contention and they've got three
straight home games that they should win
and if they win all three of them and go
into tampa bay seven and five that's
when i'll start taking them seriously
again all right one thing that i
continue to take seriously and i hope
the league takes it seriously and i am
not
this isn't something i can't wait to see
in a ooh i'm excited for it it's more of
a constant gnawing anxiety that we are
just
one moment away
from an announcement from a team
that a huge swath of players is going to
be placed on the covet 19 reserve list
and they just can't play their game on
sunday that so it's a constant
gnawing
nervousness
that for me
it it's it's getting
greater and greater as we get closer to
sunday
because even though a lot of us in the
media and a lot of fans have become
desensitized to this constant stream of
hey there's a guy on cover 19. hey
there's another guy i mean we've had a
few more pop through just during the
time that we've been on the air shireen
uh and i i just i have this dread
that at any given moment the first game
that's going to be postponed and not
made up unless there's a week 18 is
coming and i think once they cross that
bridge
it's going to be hard to not have more
games i think it's just it's indicative
and it's reflective of what's going on
currently in society and football has
been its own kind of ecosystem where
it's been able professional football not
college by any means professional
football has been able to wall it off i
think the walls are crumbling and that's
not oh i'm trying to jinx the nfl or i'm
rooting again it's reality it's reality
folks and anybody who cares about the
sport and wants to see the full season
get played would have to have a sense of
dread right now that that this may not
hold together as we get deeper and
deeper into the year and as the virus
spreads more and more
one team's fan base mike that probably
wouldn't mind having a game postponed or
canceled is the new york jets and i
can't wait to see if they're going to
get their first win because they i think
they have a chance this week a slim
chance but they do have a chance but
they are running out of chances when you
start looking at their schedule
cleveland maybe on december 27th new
england maybe on january 3rd but i'm not
thinking they win to me this is the best
chance they have for a win they have
left on their schedule
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports